I was lucky enough to go to my first
scientific meeting and as part of the
talks that I was listening to a
scientist named Michael Silverman got up
to give something it was like a 20
minute talk and he told the story about
how this beautiful glow in the dark ayuh
luminescent bacteria made light but only
when the bacteria were in a group and so
what I mean by that is when they were
alone or dilute they didn't make light
but when they grew to a certain number
it all turned on light together and what
he had discovered was that the bacteria
make a molecule which is like a word
they release it as the bacteria grow the
molecule accumulates and at a particular
amount of that molecule which tracks
with cell number all the bacteria turned
on light together and so he had shown
that these bacteria could act as a
collective and do this odd behavior
which is to make bioluminescence and I
remember sitting there thinking I have
been working on bacteria from my whole
undergraduate and graduate career I'm
kind of an expert how come I've never
heard that bacteria could do something
like that which is to act as a group and
so I was it was the only epiphany of my
life I was struck by that and I thought
and he and he said look you could make
mutants and just turn the lights off in
the room and find out bacteria that are
that either make light when they
shouldn't or don't make light when they
should and by tracking that that
bioluminescence behavior you could find
the genes and find the components and I
thought surely I'm smart enough to turn
the lights off in the room and figure
out which of these cells are dark and
bright and so I literally he made it
sound so easy and he made it sound so
amazing that these bacteria could work
in a group that I literally ran up to
the podium and it was just hanging off
the podium and said you have to let me
be your postdoc and that young woman I
don't know how I got the courage to
actually do that at that time in my life
I was like 25 years old
but it was the greatest for me moment of
inspiration ever that I actually did it
because he said yes right after a few
conversations and a resume he said yes
and I have worked on that for the rest
of my life
so far and um it was it was I should
also say or there was no example of that
right people have been working on
bacteria for almost 500 years right
bacteria have been investigated by
scientists more than any other organism
on earth and how they missed that they
could work in groups and how he found
that they could work in groups I can't
explain that but it was the most
remarkable moment of my scientific
career because it changed me forever i
sat there this young woman sat there and
I said to myself I have to work on that
and so I did
you